tu as échoué à cinq mètres du but fait
bruins il paraît que vous êtes beaux
gosses vous dire que c'est vrai mais ça
m'a fait hyper plaisir c'est bof m'ont
dit ça tout à l'heure à ce que je
parlais de kelly avec un le dos voilà on
me disait benjamin castaldi est plus
beau que son frère jamie c'est fou alors
où les chéris je sais qu'un rendez vous
chez l'ophtalmo c'est compliqué tout ça
ouais vous est inné c'est vrai on dirait
barran on dirait du cirage
il est bon c'est bon si vous êtes beau
nom mais c'est pas grave tout et je suis
passé de l'autre côté mais vous êtes
magnifique et non mais je vous dis
toutes les meufs vous kiffe
c'est normal eh ben c'est normal
normalement oui regardez c'est la
référence
mathieu vous qui connaissez in physics
est très fort en fait si vous le trouvez
vous ah non vraiment
[Applaudissements]
c'est déjà bien mais n'est pas du tout
du tout assez ses mails et chats
benjamin les meufs le kif et j'ai eu
encore la confirmation du talent heures
j'ai plein de dossiers pour vous écouter
non après mon frère fu te démerdes chez
moi ça m'arrange je vais [ __ ] en l'air
cette borne donner ça comme obliger
cabossé il aima stocks et les buriné il
a beaucoup de charme avant une élection
je suis charmé charme s'est passé quoi
c'est mieux mais le charme c'est ce
qu'on dit des gens qu'on pas de physique
ce domaine est bon ducharme
non mais il a une belle gueule il a une
gueule mathieu marchal battue ouais tu
n'as ni charme un nid physique
[Applaudissements]
alors comme ça qui se dit mais qui sait
c'est marie caillou
comment comment je n'aurais vieux déjà
en plus qu'un héros ternois derrière moi
mais tu fais des t-shirts des deux
thoniers
c'est bon que des marques me prête parce
qu'elles sont très fiers on ne regrette
rien c'est vrai que là c'est réussi mais
là c'est quoi
excusez moi et je croyais qu n'est pas
l'émission 4 go to tape à lévis a échoué
à cinq mètres du but fait c'est assez
méchant nous plaît pas ne pas la même si
tout le bella n'a dit qu'il ait échoué
battue de hambourg n'ont jamais oublié
qu'ils en ont à nancy vous plaît
laissez-moi finir un allez vous le dis à
dieu vous avez félicien peut pas vous
l'enlever vous avez fait ou
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous avez fait ou fait d'ailleurs
regardez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui ou sur nrj 12 la finale avait
rassemblé 200 5000 téléspectateurs non
205 téléspectateurs
[Musique]